[Music]
hello
this is us tug at our collective
heartstrings all season long I know I
wept and while the futures up in the air
for our favorite TV couple Jack and
Rebecca they still gave us plenty of
relationship goal moments from the
pregnant birthday dance in any state my
wife you arouse me to the coveted moon
necklace would be a 12 for you from here
out
Jack knows exactly what to say to his
wife and when to say I mean I was a
complete stranger the girl quickly took
to your brucey parenting triplets wasn't
always easy for them your emotion not
emotional but boy did they love it need
proof Thanksgiving there's no Jack
here's pilgrim Rick Jack and Rebecca
were hardcore Pittsburgh Steelers fans
Superbowl so makes sense they conceived
Kevin and Kate on the night of the Super
Bowl I see us with kids
but their life together began on their
wedding day at City Hall and in their
first apartment which they returned two
years later you take the time to
remember the newlyweds that lived here
hmm yeah
cuz I missed them some tops and who can
forget the Love Hurts
rereading their vows saying I do means
saying I will I will love you today and
every day rest of my life
[Music]